honestly if any of this ever happened to
me i would i have no idea what i'd do
i'd cry
that's all i would get in the fetal
position and cry
are you okay
hi everyone my name is madison eisman hi
there i'm israel broussard we're the
cast of fear of rain and we are here to
play would you rather
[Music]
through the woods by a killer definitely
through the woods there's more places to
hide
the killer has you know home field
advantage at that point
and you know i don't know what kind of
traps he set up i don't know
you know i like how much your thought
you're putting into this i was just
thinking open space
like more places to run
clowns don't really scare me i think the
fact
that i know clowns are people
and that like a demonic spirit could
like possess
a doll eases my mind
fight off a killer math test
i i never across the bridge of algebra
um and i i don't plan to anytime soon
i'm really good at math so
math test
[Music]
yeah i'm gonna say attic me too
basement's a little claustrophobic if
there's a fire involved
why is there a fire
what's the safest place but what if
there was a snowfall the night before
and all of the attic windows are
boarded up with snow and you can't get
through and can't get out
well i was you know i wasn't thinking
there was a window in the attic
regardless and i was just gonna try and
you know kick my way through and pry my
way out of the roof
like you know i'm assuming it's an older
house
hopefully there's a little termite
damage
i want to say buried alive because
there's a there's a possibility i can
save myself eating alive you're just
kind of screwed
i guess i'll go with barry even though
like being very alive buried alive and
burned alive are probably like my two
biggest fears
but being eaten alive is just barbaric
um so i don't think i'd pick that one
i think i'm gonna go with buried
[Music]
i think the phone line's cut i i think
phone lines cut
and i would get out well do they cut the
lines so they get you out of the house
i don't know i'm really bad honestly if
any of this ever happened to me i would
i have no idea what i'd do i'd cry
that's all i would get in fetal position
and cry
thank you everyone for watching be sure
to check out fear of rain wherever you
can rent or buy movies
[Music]
your mind is just playing tricks on you
you